yes I mean you know the mere fact is
that US government is very adept as to
obtaining attribution as proven with the
Sony hack and and now the OPM hack do
you have any doubt that this is the
Chinese I don't the information that I
have points directly to them and you
know if they if the FBI has made
attribution and they have a high rate of
confidence it's it's the Chinese and
this is this is something that we've
seen across the spectrum then looking to
gain any type of political social or
economic advantage over the United
States can you tell us a little about
about how you set about finding out
who's behind something like this and
what information you have seen sure
attribution is is made up of really too
specific parts and that's indicators so
the IP addresses and domains that are
used to conduct the attacks and in the
second part oftentimes a bit more
difficult to obtain which is the tools
techniques and procedures and that's how
the actors are perpetrating the attack
the tools that they're using and the
United States government has visibility
into the known infrastructure of these
nation states and when they see it they
recognize the signatures and they have
both indicators and TTP's you can have a
high rate of confidence it's clearly not
friendly this sort of activity is it
actually wrong in your view is it wrong
in my view Lou yes yes of course it's
you know first of all it's it's against
the law in the United States it's a
computer intrusion it's breaking into a
protected Network it's stealing very
very sensitive information millions and
millions of records detailed information
about federal employees this information
can be used for for ongoing attacks
targeted spear phishing attacks and and
that
information can be monetized as well
well what's a spear phishing attack
spear phishing attack is is if I had
asked some some information on someone
and I crafted an email and I sent that
email purportedly from somebody and in
that email either had a malicious link
or a file that was malicious and once
the user clicked on that link or clicked
on the attachment the computer would be
infected with the malware and I could
either control that computer as part of
another operation or steal information
from them and the more information you
have the more information you gather
that that that spear phishing email that
social engineering technique can be
targeted and and the the end user the
victim is more able or would be more apt
to open it up is there any truth in the
argument that everyone's at it that the
Chinese may be doing this to the US
government where the US government is
probably doing it back to other foreign
governments I don't I would i would say
that statement is is is probably correct
if you know if the United States is
being attacked and there's there's
infrastructure that that can be
dismantled that's attacking us I don't
see why the United States wouldn't do
that it's another form of it's another
form of warfare that's where the
cyberspace is going and what what
measures do you think should be taken to
protect in this case US government
employees so once the information
fortunately once that information is
gone once that information is taken it's
gone you know individuals who had their
information taken need to do the proper
steps and putting fraud alerts with the
credit reporting agencies and their and
their financial institutions going
forward though the US government needs
to step back and take a look at their
approach to cybersecurity they need to
take some steps that that a lot of
private organizations are doing which is
protect what needs to be protected
organizations private organizations such
as you know k2 intelligence will help
the way we help private organizations
protect and understand what's important
on their network the the office of OPM
has information that's that's accessible
through the internet and any internet
facing connection is is vulnerable and
and these nation-state hackers have
proven that they can break into that
area at any time mr. bogus thank you
very much